finally the video that you've all been
waiting for the top 10 textures of Dark
Souls remaster number 1 the fire
textures getting killed by Quelaag has
never looked quite so good
number 2 the two-dimensional fries look
phenomenal in 4k number 3 frampt he now
has greenish tones that make him look a
bit different to cough and this next
line of dialogue accurately sums up how
fascinating that is alright it's not a
top 10 video the title was just fate I
really just wanted to talk about my
remaster experience a little bit and
read a little bit about what you guys
have been up to most of my fun has come
from invading I felt like it was my duty
to make sure new players got the full
Dark Souls 1.0 experience so I
positioned myself for the Archy used to
be in the unpatched version of Dark
Souls and just look how much fun they're
having I like to think that they'll look
back on this fondly one day or not now
after you've found enough indictments
and hate-mail you're going to want to
put those spirits of vengeance to the
test come up to the rafters and see what
they're made of
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
these same principles of lives who sends
funhaus really and you can even stay in
character here I feel like a lot of
people forget that the iron golem
actually has arranged attack and don't
worry I know I'm being pretty evil but I
ended up balancing it out with a few
wholesome good co-op runs through the
catacombs I was essentially playing to a
guide for new players didn't end up
going so well I chose to run people
through the catacombs because I didn't
want anyone to miss this you know the
biggest gameplay change the remaster has
to offer vamos has a bonfire now and
it's placed here because this is a
really difficult stretch of the game you
have to go past a ton of skeletons then
you have to go past the wheel skeletons
then you have to beat pinwheel then you
have to survive the pitch black skeleton
hell in the tomb of the giants so this
bonfire is in the middle of all that and
it sums up the remaster for me because
this is one of the rare examples of them
changing the gameplay in a fairly
concrete way it's not just remastering
some textures but then directly opposite
this gameplay change you still have
vamos and his deep-fried voice lines
yes and if they had fixed these voice
lines and implemented some other quality
of life changes could have made this
remaster really worth it for most of you
guys watching this video instead the
remaster is just a wonderful excuse for
new players to start playing and I've
come to terms with that I've come to
terms with the fact that on PC the game
is basically just this bolstered
improved player base and I do have to
say that still is a really good feeling
it's really heartening getting instant
invasions seeing a ton of summon science
and hearing the bell of awakening being
rung pretty much constantly actually one
of the coolest things they've done is
increase the range at which you can hear
the bell of awakening being rung and you
can also hear people ringing it after
they beat quelaag as well now and if you
listen carefully you can actually hear
the birds in the background while I try
to do this recording it's really great
now if you're noticing that you're not
seeing as many summon signs and that the
people who are invading you are way too
powerful there might be a reason for
that so it seems that the developers
took this opportunity of the remaster to
test out yet another matchmaking method
which is kind of reminiscent of soul
memory from Dark Souls 2 basically the
intent here is to prevent you being
matched with people who are way more
powerful than you or way weaker than you
and this time it's based on the weapons
that you've picked up and upgraded in
addition to soul level so in the
description our posts and videos that
explain this mechanic in way more depth
but basically your character now has a
weapon level associated with him or her
and there are 15 weapon levels in the
game just like you can upgrade a basic
weapon 15 times with titanite if your
weapon level 0 and you have
upgraded anything then you'll only match
with people up to weapon level five and
so on until you reach weapon level six
where you'll stop being matched with
early weapon level characters it's a
pretty good system though there are some
problems for example if you pick up
unique early game items that are
upgraded with special materials like
twinkling titanite or demon tides night
items like a store is straight sword the
drake sword or hell even the demons
great hammer in the tutorial then you'll
be instantly propelled to weapon level
five which can open you up to higher
level PvP even if you're not using the
weapon that you picked up and if you
pick up an elemental weapon like the
lightning sphere in sense fortress then
that one will instantly take you to
weapon level 10 and this can mean you're
matched with people who have max weapon
level and again this is all without you
necessarily even using the supposedly
powerful weapon you just picked up I
don't really know if it was necessary to
put another restriction on your
multiplayer pool of people you can match
with but hey maybe they're testing the
system for their new upcoming title
you'll see it does a good job of
stopping the two extremes of weapon
levels interacting with each other but
this is only really going to affect
players who are unaware of the mechanic
as I can see dedicated griefers figuring
out how to abuse the system later down
the line by invading incensed fortress
for example where people have picked up
the lightning spear or maybe they could
just acquire overpowered spells like
dark bead that aren't affected by weapon
level at all red hey what's dark souls
without a little griefing actually if
you're watching this video when it goes
live chances are I'm doing some lore
friendly griefing of my own over on
Twitch
we're only live for patrons right now
while
learn how to stream so if you want a
private twitch link sent to your inbox
and you'd like to support the channel
then click the patreon link down below
and come check it out we've actually now
made the private twitch streams open to
all supporters no matter how much you're
contributing and I'd love to chat with
you all there we've had some pretty
hilarious moments already a fine
I finished the top ten number four the
moonlight greatsword number five the
obsidian greatsword number six Guinevere
of course number seven the piece of
cardboard that's still attached to the
silver Knight set looks great number 8
the artorias bossfight actually does
look really good with all the God rays
that shine down on the arena number nine
there are now blue streaks on the silver
tracer number ten Gwyn Gwyn spot looks
better than ever and I am always
thankful for any excuse really to
experience it again I'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]